hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't escape for the
moon is falling much like in Majora's
Mask we are about to die we survived
another night this is the last day this
time I didn't even need a dream to tell
me that I can feel it the moon will hit
Earth today we have to go to the outpost
and see if the ship is still there and
if it's not then we bend over and kiss
our asses goodbye better check this
floor first why why would I needed oh oh
he's still alive
interesting Kate what are you doing we
agreed to let him live Kate please stop
oh boy
look man don't kill him he's gonna die
from the moon anyway what would be even
be the point wait don't do it give me
one good reason I'll help you all shut
up I wasn't asking you
waste of a bullet he's learned his
lesson you're better than this that's
why I was gonna say the world ends
anyway it's over anyway huh
the world is gonna end today so what
this scum doesn't deserve to witness it
wait what you're for real
we've been guarding him for the entire
night taking turns and that was the last
night in my life
thanks David we should have killed him
right away so waste of a bullet I'm
gonna appeal to her practicality here we
might need to defend ourselves hmm I
could still just smack his head with a
pipe until his brain comes out damn you
David you're too soft I hope I'm not
gonna regret that
thank you just let me go you'll never
see me again shut up you're doing the
right thing you shut up - everybody just
shut up
I hope letting him go won't turn out to
be a mistake that was the right thing to
do I'll ask you to say that again if he
follows us and stabs our backs when we
least expected I doubt he would so it is
today is it yeah I've seen it this time
there's no way to survive this we know
where the ship is come on Kate how's
that gonna save us maybe if you tell me
more about that space station the story
would be more believable but so far just
a little longer David let's go to that
outpost it's pretty far away so we'd
better take the car and is there gonna
be a spaceship yes like a real one and
we're going into space exactly I want to
go to space oh if only what's-his-name
surfer who only wants his name oh what's
his name I miss you
much that iíve already purged your name
from my memory because I am a practical
man and I don't need to keep so much
crap inside by head but you will be
remembered whatever your name was I
guess you won't cuz I don't remember but
whatever your name was I'm sure you're
in a better place than here on earth
where we're about to blow up okay
there's a pair of gloves in the bag okay
did I get the gloves I did I did get the
gloves we decided to spare razor this
place to see enough death I just hope it
I'm not gonna regret that decision we
have to go to the outpost and see if
there's ships is still there see what I
don't get though is we spend all night
killing people and then the last one the
ringleader of the people killing people
we didn't kill right I don't know why
she didn't just shoot him right at the
doorway that was my assumption why even
have a moral dilemma but you know I
guess I guess I get it I get it I get it
okay uh how much gas is in the truck and
what's in the truck period because we're
probably gonna need to load it up with
some goodie goodies before we do
anything like that oh [ __ ] no time to
bury them I can't believe we killed them
all yeah Wow
yeah it's [ __ ] up man this useful
definitely useful crowbar always useful
hammer always useful fuel tank
definitely need that they'll probably do
us for now if I if I miss anything I can
probably come back or maybe not
considering the worlds but I'll buy Rock
I forgot about my rock I'm like dead
bird
I forgot my dead bird too and the
bandage why not take the band as well
okay we good okay we good does the kids
still have the gun good who's gonna need
it I'll keep the rock on me and the
bandage there all right let's get on our
way wherever our way may be okay so that
is 16 minutes away alright well that's
that's close enough that we can get
there but I kind of want to try the
construction site first just because now
that it's gonna be empty there might be
some supplies there that we could grab
and I could hit the gas station on the
way back give me a full tanker you know
maybe I should go down there just to see
what we need first let me do my habitual
[ __ ] saving habits hey let's just go
there first way to the man at you
counter an abandoned bus do you want to
investigate yeah sure
why not woo that's a SideReel logo on it
they were using this bus to move their
people to the launch site too bad their
driver didn't know how to drive
looks like they abandoned it here and
continued on foot maybe they left
something valuable behind alright maybe
they did maybe they didn't that looks
valuable is that a key 13 I was just
thinking about that okay good but anyway
now I know war lab 13 is so I'm gonna go
there right away because that spells to
me something special and if I spell
something special I spell it som e th
ing SPE si CI al I know my letters
alright whoa what do we have here okay a
chemical mixer I see a chemistry flask
like use that to retrieve it once the
mix is done whatever the mix maybe I've
made the calculations again the
instability ratio is too high it can't
work we have to stop the operation we
have to stop it or consequences will be
catastrophic
okey-dokey then it's not powered or it's
broken or both piece of paper this is a
list of patients yes sleeper clinic
patients each has another name assigned
in a visitor column I've recognized
those those are SideReel plexus
officials why do they match coma
patients with visitors Kate I regret
ever working for them I had no idea no
idea about what I'll tell you later
we have to focus on other things now
whatever you say okay I guess I got some
chemicals but why maybe I should have
maybe I really should have gone
somewhere else first oh well you know I
probably should have gone to the Space
Station because I know we would have
needed some things to do first before we
get anything that we need but alas I'm
an idiot and I'm just do things as Willy
okay we need gas no matter what now so
we just gotta pop this bad boy in here
yes then go here hop a dis bad boy under
there pop a dis bad boy under there and
then we Gucci er then Gucci ever Gooch
and then let's go all the way back over
here good alright there it is you mean
this what did you expect I told you the
location of this facility was
confidential don't look for any bright
neon lights or signposts yeah but still
come on the whole place is underground
we have to get inside there might be
security measures waiting for us great
we arrived at the outpost the place Kate
was after since the day we met seems
like ages ago yeah Donna does actually I
wonder why oh [ __ ] wow that guy got
blasted corpse looks melted and the sand
around it turned to glass shards I'm
guessing he was zapped fried by the Sun
but maybe maybe he was not
this thing's weighs much more than I'll
ever be able to lift what about with a
crowbar you think maybe you could do
them access pin
warning defense system activated provide
a valid ID card you have five seconds to
comply this doesn't sound good
whoo [ __ ] I know I have a valid ID card
in my cargo box for some reason I
brought it I don't know why I brought it
but I brought it okay let's try this one
warning defensive end provide a valid a
cure do five seconds five oh come on
come on come on come on hum hum hum far
far far for there's an access panel up
here it's definitely shiny they really
wanted someone to see this a metal plate
is held by some screws I don't have my
screwdriver god damnit always making
trouble for me whenever I don't want
trouble to be made stupid wait no no no
no no no no no no no no what are you
doing what are you doing get out of here
alright screwdriver let's just get my
tools back because I'm probably gonna
need them at some point and I like
having tools on me as opposed to not on
me flap flap what do we got here one of
the parts looks burned it says duplexer
on it well alright that's good to know I
guess I kind of want to see what happens
when I get zapped right on
oh my god
oh sorry you had to see that kid okay
there we go huh engine with a
transmission belt well that's
interesting
this large engine surely moves something
big however it's not moving at the
moment with a proper tool I could remove
the transmission belt all right monkey
wrench you want to remove the
transmission belt from this device it
will no longer work unless you reinstall
this action will take 10 minutes well I
don't know what I'm doing but I feel
like it has to be done at some point
fuse box all right what do we got here
Oh looks like those wires power the
electrical door mat in the elevator okay
the elevator line is down I have to find
a way to restore its power while I'm at
it I should disable the door mat before
anyone gets hurt good call buddy
Wow mama oh [ __ ] okay all right so
you're not messing around here all right
so the objective is to never let power
short out which is interesting I kind of
like that that's a new twist on this
whole dingle-dangle thing just have this
all set up and ready to go so as soon as
I flip this it should go to the elevator
poink yeah all right cool well finally
what took you so long
why didn't we just jump over it uh well
you know what Cody I don't know why you
didn't just jump over it why didn't you
just you know you could have just run
for it there was like a five-second
delay you would have been fine okay
whatever what do you think of this place
well finally er yeah it's not over yet
the worst is yet to come
you know how to lift the spirits Kate
I'm just being realistic we got here and
that's great we've been through a lot
but it's still far from over
all right so today's day yes we either
fly or we fry I can't believe you're
able to joke about earth being destroyed
then again I can hardly believe the
earth biz being destroyed in the first
place oh yes this world is lost there's
nothing we can do just escape I guess
you're not sharing any more details on
our actual plan of what we do once we
take off I'm also recalling the name of
the game is don't escape and we're
trying to escape I don't think we're
gonna be able to escape I have my big
old doubts right now taking off isn't
even certain the ship might not flyer
might explode in the air if it's damaged
there are a million with things that can
go wrong so yes let's focus on those
things now
learn about everything soon enough
alrighty then about Cody I was thinking
about Cody jeez David what do you want
me to say
that I like him yes I like him there are
you happy well yeah still think he
overreacted I just wanted to ask he's a
good kid David okay I'm surprised he's
still holding up after all that happened
a lot of adults would have had a
breakdown yet he's still going it's
admirable alright okay real real nice
about you you know I'm not gonna ask you
about razor okay let's see if the
elevators working now huzzah
we're good okay good for us you guys
want to come I'll go down okay fine Wow
okay I thought it was just gonna be
spooky darkness
not that I mind spooky darkness but I
that's what I thought it was gonna be
okay piece of paper you're not gonna say
anything about the fuel burning catalyst
formula this experimental liquid greatly
increases fuels power output
oh you don't be then Kate what is that a
trajectory map why does it go to the
moon we are not going to the moon are we
you said we're going to Space Station I
never said the Space Station wasn't on
the moon what but the moon is gonna
you've got to be kidding please tell me
you are correct me if I'm wrong but
isn't the moon going to hit us in less
than 12 hours why the hell would we want
to go there it's the only way you have
to believe me I don't know if I have any
reason to believe you now you promised
us safety you promised us an escape you
said you wanted to leave this planet
those aren't the exact words I used how
can I explain it to you there is
something in that moon base that will
help us sidereal has a base there what
could possibly help us if we reach the
moon an hour before impact I wasn't
there moon base destroyed in the mining
accident it was but they have another
base on the moon it's called sidereal
plex one and they how should I put this
how do you think SideReel has all this
technology private space shuttles moon
bases electric doormats weather drones
heat absorbers the means to accidentally
blow up the whole damn moon I'm not sure
I follow they're getting that technology
from other worlds like other planets no
other Earth's they are in contact with
other versions of sidereal Plexus a vast
network of connections across the
endless universes constantly discovering
new versions of the world as they go our
world is merely one page in an enormous
library of worlds they have access to do
you expect me to believe all that I
don't really care if you do help me off
this planet or get out of the way please
don't fight you
if we're going to die we can be together
right I don't want to be alone again Oh
God so sad why so is that all right can
i is this remote gonna boo it has
batteries inside good thing they're
secured with the screw otherwise someone
would just take them like me like me oh
why is it on the moon even weak signals
could corrupt our devices the moon's
body shields our facility from Earth's
intense radio interference is this a
one-way trip yes where will we end up in
in one state a safe world will be
selected you are likely to survive
intact who is selected for this rescue
why is X not here we had limited time
and resources and we could only bring as
many people as we gathered since the
incident if you believe someone crucial
to our operation is missing please
report it to your supervisor why are we
only taking one ship the other ship is a
reserved spare vehicle don't worry we
have directed our workers to multiple
Launchpad outposts no one will be left
behind as long as they present value to
the company Wow good great that's great
hope I have value let me use this on
this remove the batteries without them
the remote is useless okay
well you know I guess that's fine
because that's what I was going for
anyway all right is this for an xn card
an old fingerprint scanner that's
different okay I don't have that it's
locked
it's a fingerprint scanner that's what I
thought hey Kate do you think your
fingerprint would work no oh wait I saw
that there's a finger scanner on that
door yeah so since you know so much
about SideReel I thought you could David
I oh come on you wouldn't have any idea
about this place if you weren't somehow
involved even if I was do you think I'd
still be here if I was important enough
for them to save me humor me
ah happy now okay well time to might as
well try everything yeah wow there it is
look at that I told you it bit here
I'm sure you hadn't doubted me for a
second I admit this looks pretty
impressive it's like a regular space
shuttle but smaller and more fancy it is
promising can we go inside don't
celebrate just yet there's space for two
rockets in the silo see one launch pad
is empty so they took one shuttle and
left the other behind
why maybe one was sufficient remember
they weren't trying to save as many
people as possible they were just saving
who they thought was it worth saving or
the other one was broken anyway a bit of
time has passed the ship requires a
general inspection before it's even
remotely safe to use
okey dokey then we found a space shuttle
okay what can we do to improve the
condition of the ship oh that's what we
have to do now I understand okay alright
well let's go for this control room what
have we got here Wow there's a part at
the bottom that seems to be open a part
came loose I'll take it I hope it wasn't
important
yeah it's probably not I'm gonna leave
the house keys here I guess I'll be fine
is it a duplexer it's a duplexer
it's a DubLi it's a dupe Lee this
computer controls hatch do you want to
open the Silas house sure oh yeah and
get her open operation to bleed hell
yeah I should save before I push any
more buttons that's probably not the
best thing to do when you find a
spaceship is start ramming bamming on
random buttons everywhere you go radar
screen system failure well the radar
won't be useful to us anyway right
probably not
but on the other hand I mean it's not
like there are any planes left in the
air or helicopters but who knows David
who knows a good call good call
Sal Abbas's open hull integrity check
fail their compositions selected fuel
mixture missing fuel catalysts missing
air supply ok warning diagnostic system
is damaged please perform a manual
onboard inspection to complete the
Diagnostics Oh gay that doesn't seem
good adjustment of fuel mixture might be
required alright oh oh it's one of these
deals okay alright okay I see how we're
doing here this is gonna take me a while
ain't it yeah yeah
there I don't think it could be done any
better than this yeah yeah couldn't
noway know how superb like that superb
I'm superb let's go back to the
Diagnostics though the ok fuel catalyst
is missing so we need to go make the
fuel catalyst I'm assuming
hey Cody do you have any genius ideas
about this you like it here Cody huh
it's kind of spooky in here can we just
go to space now we're working on it you
look anxious I can't wait I want to go
to space already also kate says the moon
is gonna hit Earth today can we watch
that from above because that sounds like
really dangerous sure we'll be safe in
our spaceship in space can I tell you a
secret David sure I'm scared like you
almost all the time I'm just trying to
think about going to space so I don't
think about the end of the world
Cody what I just want to say I'm proud
of you for what for being scared fear is
something we all feel Cody feeling fear
doesn't mean you're not brave and you're
the bravest kid I've ever met I am yeah
and I'm sure you'll love it in space you
still think Katie's mean you know she
wouldn't be Kate if she wasn't a little
bit mean maybe it's her way to show she
likes someone you know like she tries to
be a badass which is pretty cool but at
the same time she has to show her
friends that they are on the same side
that's very wise Ray's or is free I hope
you're not scared by that know that guys
always lose no matter what are you
saying that the good guys always let the
bad guys leave yeah most of the time
then they can return in other comic
books and make some more trouble but you
said you're not afraid of him coming
back yeah because we're gonna beat him
again good point good good point anyway
let me go see where this duplexer goes
Oh actually let me go to the launch pad
first it's got to be something else here
fuel catalyst console this console has
an inlet for catalyst fluid that will be
injected into the fuel tank
all right socket what is the socket for
this is a high voltage socket for
specialized equipment
ooh-kay and up button hmm I hear the
engine working but the elevator doesn't
seem to be moving without a transmission
belt this engine is useless a conundrum
you don't have anything else to say do
you I'm not even gonna ask you about
rays or because they don't care about
your opinion oh let's go back
okay let's go put this duplexer back in
because there's definitely gonna need to
be something there so we could get the
transmission belt here but I'm guessing
oh wait no we can take this now because
I'm thinking that was only for the silo
be done there okay let me put something
in the car first I had to put a bunch of
stuff in the car I still out this floppy
disk phase control light I don't know
what that means not a heart isn't sure
what that's for but let's go up here
let's see about a duplexer
oh yeah that's for the radar oh maybe I
should put the plate back on they do
anything with this I guess I have this
now this is mine and there are many like
it but this one is mine hey does your
finger work on the fingerprint scanner
let me try okay you can't do that oh you
big [ __ ] baby let's go to launch pad
let's bring the transmission belt over
to the engine yes please go up this
please let's see what's in the Jeep
please alright so how does it look you
tell me I don't know much about
spaceships I always imagined it would be
more horizontal it can be confusing but
the ship will rotate to a horizontal
position after we launch still it kind
of looks like some sort of spaceship bus
with all those seats its purpose was to
drive people to and from the moon kind
of is a space bus anyway look around for
any systems that seem to be missing all
I know is the system is missing if it's
not there
come on David you're smart it's not
rocket science hey are we ready to
launch
I made some calculations we barely have
enough fuel to get to our destination we
have to limit our weight and you seem to
be carrying a lot of stuff with you I
like picking things up you never know
when you're gonna need a water sprayer
ah now you have to say goodbye to your
belongings take only things that way say
one kilogram in total that's not good
one kilogram fought one kilogram one
kilogram all right whoa nav control chip
is empty wait huh the lithium hydroxide
filter is installed everything seems to
be fine here okay huh all right toolbox
we got in here I found a glue gun in the
toolbox it seems to be out of power
how did why would a glue gun be oh it
won't last for too many uses though okay
it's all their tanks auxiliary air tanks
are in place everything seems to be fine
here labeled engine calibrator but
there's nothing here alright and then a
socket this is a high voltage socket for
specialized equipment okay I'm not
seeing anything else there's nothing
interesting left in the box okay so we
still need a lot of stuff so we need the
fuel catalyst number one a dangerous
looking crack oh yeah that looks
dangerous hey this fin is cracked this
can't be good right what we're here see
you think it's serious looks like it
might be best-case scenario we will lose
a lot of thrust from air resistance in
the worst case we explode during the
ascent oh well looks like the old blue
guns gonna come out and play come on off
the bench mr. glue gun
don't you worry this will get it all
[ __ ] and span boink
yes gluing the crack in the spaceship
cell is totally gonna help hey listen
listen buddy listen great but I need
something to create an airtight seal
over this crack how about a glue gun
this guy is so stupid you glue the metal
plate on to the fin you go up into space
it's so simple
you saw me so smart so while you let me
do thinking and you do the gluing huh
how about we go from there to that yeah
that's what I thought I think I need a
welder or something are you sure you
know what you're doing David oh yeah Oh
big yeah Oh
biggest of the years let's look at the
radar what do we got going on what the
an airplane an actual flying airplane
wait a second okay why hush see any
difference no should i if it was flying
you'd see it move it's not airborne
I thought radar was supposed to be
detecting things up in the sky yes it
also detects active transponders beacons
installed in aircrafts so we're looking
at a possible location of an airplane on
the ground
yeah seems somebody didn't disabled
their transponder which might end
crash give me your map all estimate this
position based on the radars readings
fascinating okay all right good good
that's good now we can go find a plane
and potentially get more goodies and
maybe find someone's finger dad be nice
airplane perfect don't know what I'm
gonna find out an airplane that must
have been a tough landing believe me
I've seen worse found out that the plane
seems to be mostly intact so it's a good
landing in my book did it belong to
sidereal fleet most likely whatever it
was carrying might still be on board
come on
I'd like the spaceship better can we go
back to the spaceship later okay oh I
make so much weird sounds are you sure
you want to dig with the bare hands oh
excuse me
excuse me you only use a shovel to dig
yeah let's do this
ah hell yeah let's go in here krei
labeled seven Wow what convenient
labeling craze sealed shut I won't be
able to open to all Thank You crowby ah
let's see if we can narrow down which
one we're gonna look for maybe there's a
manifesto or something like that or a
manifest not a man of the thing hello
pilot is this person dead it would seem
so kid let's see if he had something
that might be useful to us wait what if
he comes back to life and bites you Cody
lacks David as a professional he has
searched like a dozen corpses I sure
have yeah what what happened did you
just move Cody
want to wait outside Cody no I want to
see that you look at the mummified
course are you sure you want to touch it
and search for anything useful wait what
if Cody's right what if good what if
he's right I think flashed for long
enough yes just a piece of paper cargo
manifest let's take a look I was right a
manifest
okay gaskets various sizes voltmeters
nuts and bolts sizes 10 through 15
navigation navigation ships instant
noodles air tanks wires assorted all the
above is property of sidereal plexus so
I need number six number four
maybe number five maybe number seven I
don't think I'm gonna need anything else
here maybe I need a gasket I don't know
probably other things could be wrong
with the ship and they would need things
like this like a specific size of nut
and/or bolt but let's go four five six
and seven five definitely not sure why
it's gonna take nine minutes to open
that but okay sure let's see what's
inside a lot of instant noodles hell
yeah let's get four open this one I had
the nav chips okay what's this a heap of
electronic chips we got an amp okay
that's good I need to put some stuff in
the truck food and maybe we will need
food for the trip I guess that is
important air tanks so we're looking for
six and probably seven eventually but
let's look at six the crates open I
hoping I'm not wasting too much time on
that air tanks not many they seem quite
large and heavy okay good oh no wait we
had air tanks oh god damn it okay all
right
oh let's so skip it for that for now
we've got enough I think we need that
computer we need the computer why didn't
I hit the construction oh let's go back
here first
oh go go go come on everybody's not
enough of a hurry let's go let's go
let's go oh I didn't cut off the guy's
finger oh god I didn't do that here's an
average it for this chunk this thing's
good we just need engine calibrator I
don't know what that means but an engine
calibrator is what I need we already
have the air tanks because I'm an idiot
let's just [ __ ] put it try it again
the air tank is already installed of
course it is I just have a big [ __ ]
air tank because I'm an [ __ ] alright
so we got to go probably to the
construction site they probably have
some specialized tools that are gonna be
able to help me fix this crack okay
we're at the construction site let's see
what we've got here
Oh a magazine a last issue we
investigated sigh real Plexus sleeper
clinic well the problem still exists and
people are out there are still being
controlled by mine transferring
technology we get weekly conspiracy
began to wonder why does sidereal Plexus
have this technology in the first place
together with all their other
advancements in space exploration energy
and computers these days sidereal Plexus
seems to be the first to come up with
anything to us this just seems a bit too
suspicious they might have the best
engineers in the world but
can't explain how they're producing
countless advancements introducing many
of them into our everyday lives one can
only wonder what fraction of their
technology were actually saved Moore's
law states that processing power of
computers doubles every 18 months
however since SideReel opened their
computer research branch two years ago
this increase is triple this defies any
logic and leads to the obvious
conclusion aliens we at weekly
conspiracy believe sidereel plexus has
been in contact with extraterrestrial
beings since its founding when you think
about it it's been right in front of us
the entire time side realizing stellar
or astral it's pretty solid proof that
their technology who wasn't created on
this planet with by allowing alien
spaceships to land in their secret
facilities for by opening portals to
other universes they are importing this
technology from another worldly place
the real question is what is the price
that they are paying well maybe we'll
never find out because we weekly
conspiracy fear this price might hurt us
all I don't know what this is but
whatever aliens man no David no aliens
don't believe in everything you read
even if it's not far from the actual
truth it isn't let's move David okay
whatever is a welding kit how do I get
the welding kit me want welding kit me
want
ooh me one big li ooh
how me get oh me want it about me rope
it with a hook it's a delicate piece of
equipment I can't just toss a hook gun
at it in hopes of pulling it back I
don't think it's that delicate but
whatever
mr. delicate [ __ ] man there's got to
be like a stepladder or something like
that or some way to get up there I'm
sure there is but I just don't know what
it is but either way I need to get this
[ __ ] God Wow I left I left the chemical
composition thing in the truck because
I'm an idiot all right hmm interesting
uh button button button button
okay so I need to put the chemicals in
the thing all right but but but
mix the selective components this will
take a while this action will take 15
minutes
the mixer is finished worthless see a
tray full of disgusting goop yuck it
looks and smells disgusting I don't
think that's the result I wanted I'll
throw it away okay interesting so I
think I'm missing some components here
I'm not sure
oh wait up there oh okay I'll you sneaky
peeky I see you ah interesting okay
alright sneaky peeky okay so there's
four blues so we need at least four
blues there's two Reds and three blacks
so that would be it
yes bada bing bada boom put it in the
bottle and we're good to go right we got
it right that's all we need
yeah bottle of catalyst okay we got that
was easy enough for just if I would have
seen the other ones I would have been
done that sooner but oh well alright so
maybe I could just run a few laps of
fuel up to the ship anyway from the gas
station
someone's got to have a ladder someone
somewhere has a ladder do you have a
ladder no you don't have a ladder okay
you don't have a ladder that's fine ouch
this man Oh God Oh oh there was
scaffolding right here I'm a dumb-dumb
oh I'll buckle this was used to pull
heavy weights up and down maybe this
could be used to help me somehow maybe
with a thing on a rope ah got it okay
now that was too easy I should have
known I should have known all right so
now I'm all good God wait no that we
still need like the engine control unit
which I don't know where that would be
but that's what we need so where in the
world would I get something like an NG
control unit I don't even know what that
means maybe maybe I could take one from
the plane maybe I don't think the plane
would have had one but I think the plane
might have you used one maybe anyway I'm
gonna cut off this guy's finger no give
me your finger give me your finger
I want your finger I'm gonna take your
finger give me your finger I want it I
need it maybe at the bus maybe someone
got flung from the bus I feel like
there's got to be something else here
right it couldn't have been just this
thing right there had to be something
else to it
one would think one would assume one
would suspect there's something I'm not
being told let's go ahead and weld this
crack at least okay so god I left it in
the oh I left it in the truck
why did leave it I don't know I left it
in the why did you leave it in the
druggie I don't know why did anybody
leave it in the drug why would somebody
leave something like that in truck I
dunno oh the SideReel plexus building
there was also a corpus uh there's a
body in here I know there is there's
there's a body there's definitely a body
in here not that buddy not that body not
the body of the former friend
I mean dice only say former cuz he's
dead now but there's more body right
here this guy give me your finger take a
finger for good luck or a fingerprint
reader it wasn't that bad the body's
pretty much mummified nevertheless I
don't want to do this ever again yes
I've got a finger where's my finger
there it is a human finger right cool
good now we're good to go now we may
leave up with this in here yeah and we
don't even need to fuel it again not
again cuz I think we don't even need to
go out again because we got everything
we need except an engine control unit
but I'm gonna get it in here with the
finger I bet I bet I bet I bet I bet I
bet you wanna bet cuz I bet there we go
there we go baby there we go baby
give me an engine control unit a weird
device yeah that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm [ __ ] talking
about
that is the thing that I am discussing a
weird device here give me that weirdness
Oh I want the weird yeah make it weird
for me
yeah what do we got weird The Voice
calibrator and a little filter the
calibrator is what I need I'm pretty
sure oh yeah baby give me the calibrator
give me the calibrator
oh yeah calibrate all over me I'm gonna
calibrate you and you're gonna calibrate
me and did I get the metal blade I sure
did right Linkous the weakest that's
done is oneness let me take this just
because I needs it this is going great
this it's going great calibrate boom oh
yeah yeah calibre everything seems to be
fine here everything's good all right
looks like we might be about ready to go
let me check the control room real quick
and then I gotta make a dumb piece of
all my unnecessary [ __ ] okay radar
screen selected field miss sure I wonder
what would happen if oh yeah the
catalyst I wonder what would happen if I
didn't open the hatch when we tried to
launch Blanc owner would ever let you or
the catalyst in the injector okay I
think is wheeze aboutis ready to goes so
we need to basically pick what we need I
think food I think food is a good idea I
need to reduce my weight down as much as
possible so I think the food is in the
truck so let's make this decision now
and then once we're ready to go we go
baby and we're gonna go so far fast hot
and heavy and super sweet so I need only
a kilogram is what I've been told I can
only have a kilo grams so a bag of food
that's good no hammer no shovel no
Kroeber let me just go ahead and drop
things you've been good to me but not
right now you've been good to me but no
longer let's see duct tape you never
know you never know when you need ok
kids a knife sorry
not coming with us gloves now we don't
need gloves in space glue gun probably I
don't know why but sure okay chemical
formula you don't weigh anything so
you're fine a gun sorry bub you gotta go
rock it pains me to say this but you
must stay here on the
earth from whence you came and from
where you shall return all right so I've
got point eight kilograms a lighter you
never know it's weightless so that's
fine ID badge yes you're just in case
is it nudes uh that's one so it's a good
bit of food I guess I could check the
house but I don't know if I would need
to I don't know what else could possibly
be at the house that would help me
launch this spaceship and survive long
enough I think this is enough it's
exactly one kilogram
I've got food duct tape some goodie
goodies some batty Betty's and I can't
think of anything else that we would
possibly need let's do this let's
[ __ ] do this
are we ready to launch ready when you
are David ready to launch are you sure
you're ready to launch if so is there
any item you'd like to use how much does
a water sprayer way you did mention that
by a word now let's launch it let's see
what could possibly go Ryan's fine just
launch it all right the world is ending
the moon cracked into pieces was moving
rapidly towards the planet both
celestial potties pulling each other
apart all systems green well some
systems are green you didn't have time
to check every last nut or seal like
people did before launching rockets in
the old days Kate looked at you with her
headset on engines ready initiating
launch procedure overriding safety
protocols manual controls engaged nats
was open leaving a clear way towards the
sky it would really suck if that wasn't
open five three dude well buckle up it's
gonna be one hell of a ride would zero
the acceleration force pushed you hard
into your seat squeezing all the air
from your lungs the rocket began its
ascent you look back to see Cody in a
seat the kid had been through a lot yet
he was lucky enough to end up with you
on this ride the seat next to him was
empty at least you kept the kids safe
like the big old man wanted the
spaceship climbed through the sky while
Keith struggled with the engines power
raised or traveled alone bruised and
hurt hearing a loud roar in the sky he
turned around and gazed up he sadly
watched to soar clenching his jaws hard
as he was clenching his fists looking
around the wasteland he decided this
place was as good as any other he sat
down and waited looking at your ship
going up in the moon
going down sergeant his men were
standing on top of a hill he traveled
far west since you would last seen him
the whole squad raised their heads
engaged in the sky tracing the bright
light of your rocket would you look at
that smirk Sarge slowly shaking his head
that kid actually did it good luck with
whatever you find there he added before
he turned away the whole squad decided
to open their last bottle of whiskey and
drink it as the world around them
started falling apart the vessel was
gaining altitude at least life support
seemed to work fine because the default
setting had been corrupted you were
forced to create the fuel mixture
yourself composition was perfect maximum
efficiency meant a lot of thrust and a
smooth ascent you installed navigation
ship in the ship's systems with its help
Kate was guided with a set of numbers
angles and coordinates which is always
better than just guessing you install
the calibrator onboard it precisely
calibrated all the engines making them
really well coordinated good thing you
noticed and fix the crack on the ship's
fin with your repairs approved to add
almost no air resistance Kate managed to
compensate for the slight aerodynamics
changes with her piloting skills you
prepared a special catalyst for the fuel
it caused the main rocket to burn fuel
quicker but it also made the reaction
much more powerful click to view the
summary you made it orbit and from there
was surprisingly a sure way to the moon
Kate flew the ship towards the lunar
pace
Wow it's a quick trip football okay all
right well you could have landed on that
part of it I guess but oh well good
enough interesting
Wow Kate are you all right that wasn't
one of my best landings I've never seen
you do any better it could be worse
though couldn't it my defense it was my
first time landing on the moon Cody how
you doing Cody you okay oh I don't know
can you stand
I think what's that sound are we gonna
die we're losing air David now is the
time to use the space suits if we have
space suits oh we have space suits good
okay are you old enough oh I feel dizzy
and I don't like spaceships anymore can
we go outside yet you're probably right
we should hurry up all right booboo I'm
very slow to space you for some reason
wow we made it we actually made it I
never doubted we would but I guess I owe
it to you come on let's move it's not
safe in here all right okay I'll be back
maybe initiating decompression procedure
Boosh decompression to bleed and here we
are
Wow I guess we're going to the moon base
[ __ ] I guess I'll unlock it no one worry
about a thing I've got it it's no
problem I don't mind doing everything
myself okay a rotate fifth ring whoa
what am i it's like some maze that's
probably a reference to something that I
don't know all right I think it's safe
to remove the suits great because I'm
almost out of oxygen okay so what now
let's look around okay
anybody home anybody card reader slot
for an access card how about this not
really okay how about this no oh good
good good good good yeah I brought that
oh [ __ ] insufficient priviledges well
okay that's good
Nexus denied okay let's try the other
side then there's gotta be someone else
or at least someone else's card here
somewhere
what are those Kate sleeper pods why are
there people here you said they all left
you said they went to a different
dimension or something they did is what
they left behind Kate you said they
escaped they did David check out their
neural activity monitors they're flat
because their bodies are here sleeping
but their minds left this place they
traveled through the realm of dreams and
already woke up in safety months ago
pods to sustain their empty bodies here
not that it's required but if or any
reason anyone wanted to get back they
still can at least for now
wait I've got some questions so it's
just some sort of hibernation yes so the
body doesn't die while the consciousness
is elsewhere what happens if the body
dies in any normal circumstance your
mind would die to the side real has
discovered something I don't know what
it is exactly but they can completely
separate the mind from the body so when
the moon hits Earth and everything here
blows up it won't matter them realm of
dreams a poetic name but quite graphic
sidereal is discovered that the human
mind is capable of accessing this place
a vast network connecting every mind as
it later turned out it reached for
beyond every mind in the world it can
connect Minds across universes why do
the sleeper pods have to be on the moon
why even bother fly here if all they do
is put you in a pod their pods are
extremely susceptible Danny interference
especially radio waves humanity used to
produce a giant mess of electromagnetic
waves of various frequencies radio
broadcast TV communications I can go on
and on SideReel found it next to
impossible to come up with a location
desolate enough for their sleeper pods
to work as intended Faraday cage
shielding was partially selective but it
was apparently causing some side effects
early experiments led to some awful
failures it finally came up with the
idea the only thing that would shield
the sleeper pods well enough would be
the
what about the moon earth communications
what about radio waves from space
don't they interrupt the sleeper ponds
sidereal loans communication devices
work on frequencies outside the harmful
spectra space radiation damn it David I
don't know they must have found a way
around it I'm not a physicist sounds
convenient yeah you don't know the way
we get into those pods and we dream our
way out of here wake up somewhere safe
I'm not sure I feel about that idea then
again what do we have to lose a black
coward a system memory 32 megabytes
floppy drive no interesting I've got a
floppy there's a console seems to be
locked okay let's put the card in the
other side oh [ __ ] there that goes [ __ ]
okay that's not good [ __ ] Wow okay I
should hurry then oh [ __ ] access granted
okay here we go oh [ __ ] okay oh yeah you
only have to open and use the UH okay oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh God
sleeper pod unlocked okay anything else
that we need to do let's go let's go oh
my god oh my god oh oh oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] Oh God go I gotta put the
floppy in the floppy the floppy let me
just check the status before I started
loading software into this okay
all right uh Rod's active warning phase
control cannot date unable to select
destination amazing mercy Mo's no
responsible to remember all awesome
personality merge oh no no no check that
again maybe it was just a glitch it
still says phase controller color up did
it has already happened he's happening
Kate you're not making any sense
Kate yeah wait what what is a phase
controller it's a system designed to
transmit human consciousness to a
selected target target a human in
another world yes usually an otherwise
brain-dead clone they've prepared
especially for this purpose or a patient
in a coma in the worlds like ours where
cloning has not been developed yet this
is how they used to navigate between
worlds go to sleep here target a
sleeping human vessel in another world
and wake up there I'm not sure if this
is more terrifying or more unbelievable
if that controller is disabled we can't
select a target body or world
okay well [ __ ] so what's the emergency
merge mode when the primary phase
controller is disabled the backup system
kicks in it targets a random world and
random sleeping person without their
consent yes however for some reason when
this happens you almost always end up in
your own body but in a different world
oh I get it I get what it's saying I get
it this is how I would keep everyone
alive because that would have knowledge
ahead of the time and it it's having
it's having a canonical way that you can
play the game again and know what to do
it is that's amazing the dreams that's
what the dreams are that's what it's
saying we can end up in limbo in a dream
world without bodies or trying to or we
can wake up in our own bodies in a
different world of a different version
of our world like one where all this
never happened
a world where there was no lunar
explosion in 1996 hopefully yes
hopefully Oh what do you mean it's
already happened I'm not sure the dreams
we both had warning you about incoming
threats showing me where the SideReel
office building was those might have
been our own memories from our past
lives that would mean I've been through
this we all have the computer says
something about memory loss yeah when
your mind ends up in your own body in a
different world this is what happens you
merge your current memories become
distant like a dream that you forgot
doesn't sound like we're going to make
it in one piece after all it's better
than dying completely I guess but if my
past me warned me about the incoming
events who warned him another me who
warned that other me when did it all
begin as far as I know the number of
worlds might be infinite it's better to
not think about it right we have no
other choice David we've got to use
those pods whether they're fully
operational or not can't we fix the
damaged systems even if we knew how it
would probably take days we definitely
don't have that much time let's do this
quick this whole place is falling apart
well before you do that I'm gonna plop
II this thing I've inserted the phase
control light disk drive be the computer
reads it this program will not replace
phase controller however it will
increase your memory transfer route rate
in emergency mode oh so there's another
floppy disk somewhere in the world to
get
there's another floppy disk somewhere
and this this is just saying that you
would go through it again and again
until you get it right I just want to
see what happens if you just wait here
ah that's so cool that's such a cool
idea it's it's is the concept of looping
over and over again but that's just
really cool that's well done I like that
a lot
ah that's cool
he's about to go boom aren't we yeah
wheeze about to go boom uh oh I just
want to see if it actually blows up if
it does blow up then cool if it doesn't
blow up then I'll get in the pod doesn't
seem like it's doing anything I was
watching the shadow with the shadow
wasn't getting any closer and then the
earth stopped moving I don't think it's
doing anything damn I wanted to see it
go kaboom probably gonna see it go
kaboom once this lands all these bodies
go bye-bye I think I should ask the
others if they want to go first
Kate I've inserted phase controller
light I've inserted a special disk onto
the console
what disc a disc I found in the SideReel
plexus office the computer says it will
increase the memory transfer or
something like that do you think it's
gonna help yeah I guess so even a single
helper program like this could make a
huge difference if our memories are
transferred intact or at least in a
greater more consistent rate this could
be huge David this actually could help
us okay alright time to sleep right or
should I go first
it's okay remember to turn off the
lights and promise you won't do anything
stupid I've ever done anything stupid
yeah you're funny hey Cody
um never change okay okay see you soon
good night Kate alright David so here we
are at the end of the road or is it the
beginning I wouldn't have made it here
if it wasn't for you are you getting
emotional now I think I've spent too
much time with you where do you hope to
wake up in a bed in a world where they
have a moon and lattes I hope that's
what happens me too
bye David until we meet again just don't
point your gun at me when we do okay
can't promise that
hey there Cody it's time I don't want to
sleep I know but we all have to I won't
be able to sleep now I'm too scared this
machine will help you
come on don't be scared what will happen
where will we go
I don't know but it's gonna be all right
David I don't want to be alone again
you won't be where ever you wake up I'll
find you promise promise this is so cool
what's amazing is it ties all of script
welders other storylines together you
know it ties it like all the deep sleep
games they're about this in this world
of dreams I love that it's it's like
it's like tie aah
God it wraps everything up I mean of
course they'll be like potholes and what
that but I'm not gonna focus on that
because open the new shove it all
doesn't matter
what matters is that it's cool thing
what the Oh
oh [ __ ] never mind error main powers
offline unable to initiate sleeper pod
oopsies
well that's not good oh oh oh maybe I
shouldn't have waited so long you have
to take a look at the screen realized
the sleep pods have their independent
power reserves you won't be able to
initiate another pot unless the main
powers back there's some uh necessary
systems powered such as communication
array there's a standard procedure so
the crew is able to call for help but
there's no one that can help me now
you could try to reroute the power ah do
it rerouting power to reserves main
power restored all right let's try that
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh God Oh how about we
go maybe I should have I should have I
shouldn't awaited I shouldn't no way
didn't looked I shouldn't have looked
and waited I shouldn't have looked and
or waited oh all right ah yes I've all
right just a little more drama just
before the end I guess I could have seen
it go kaboom but whatever Wow
what a nightmare
it all felt so real I feel there was
something more in that dream something
sad and important why do I feel like
this already happened yet something is
different I'm gonna find out what I love
that I love that I love that I love that
I love that so much I love that I love
that that is Wow script welder you have
outdone yourself you have outdone
yourself incredibly I love that so much
and the game is not even over yet
even if the credits are rolling here I
know that's not the end there will be
more don't escape for in the very near
future this is not the end because that
is just the beginning
now I am armed with knowledge so there
might be one maybe two more episodes
with which I will plow my fists of
justice into this ow my head into this
Wow IQ I got us up what the [ __ ] what
the what the hey well you all right
there you're right there buddy you you
you Oh
the awakening Oh
Oh wake up David you have to wake up you
have to wake up dark apply our effects
that's so [ __ ] cool that's so [ __ ]
cool so [ __ ] cool yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] Wow my god spiders that the
legs of spiders isn't what a nightmare
it all felt so real spiders feel there
was something more on that dream
something sad and important what I feel
like this already happened if something
is different I'm gonna find out what my
back of Pecha alright so yeah it's it's
the same but it's different so with that
being said I will continue this armed
with the power of knowledge facing new
crisis ease oh that's horrible cobwebs
that's the are the spiderwebs on the
wind they're huge I think my name there
might have been more than just a dream I
still have a couple of hours but I have
to find a shelter fast alright so we
will continue this very soon yeah Dave
what the awakening here we'll continue
this in the next episode thank you
everybody so much for watching and if
you have not played this for yourself
get it support script well they're for
making such a cool and interesting game
with a really really convoluted but
fascinating story
it is awesome link is in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]